[Music]
spider-man into the spider-verse is
about to get is sequel shortly after the
release and 2018 it was already clear
that the animated movie spider-man will
get a sequel the response two years ago
was incredibly positive both by fence
and critics the highlights of the hype
surrounding the new Spidey was the award
of the highest price in the film
industry an Academy Award after the
release date of spider-man into the
spider-verse
- was moved from April to October 2022
due to the pandemic it was not clear
when the production could begin as you
can read in a tweet from Nick Conda On
June 8th the work has finally started
now Sony's production team will do
everything possible to ensure that the
incredible box office result of 376
million u.s. dollars from 2018 will be
reached again Hakeem dos Santos will
direct the film the script is by
Zombieland - and Wonder Woman 1984
author Dave Callahan how the story of
Miles Morales and his colleagues Peter
Parker spider-man spider ham and many
others will continue is not yet known
the use American cinema release of
spider-man into the spider-verse - is
the 7th of October 2022 the Alien
franchise has existed for over 40 years
in the past the film studio Fox was
responsible for the film series but
since the sensational Fox take over the
responsibility for a sequel now lies in
the hands of Disney for a long time it
was discussed whether the alien films
are in line with Disney's child and
family friendly image and whether fans
can expect new films at all then about a
year ago it was finally confirmed
director Ridley Scott is already working
on the script for alien covenant to
Scott recently announced his plans for
the franchise in an interview with a Los
Angeles Times and some fans will
certainly be pleased the director told
them that the alien series still has a
few more miles of the tank and that it
is time for a new development above all
the question of how the creature was
created and what the big loads of acts
on board the spaceship is all about must
now be resolved whoever knows the alien
movie from 1979 will know what we're
talking about and attempt to close the
gap to the old alien blockbuster was
made in the last decade with the
prequels Prometheus and alien covenant
nevertheless the questions surrounding
the xenomorph acts as well as the exact
purpose of the spaceship ever remained
unsolved so far when exactly the new
film will be released and if the title
alien covenant - will stay yes
is still not certain it can be assumed
that the development is still in a very
early face the Brent new streaming
servers HBO max seems to be particularly
concerned about the child friendliness
of the Looney Tunes franchise which has
been in existence since 1930 as it turns
out this series around Bugs Bunny still
hasn't lost any of its charm in the
first week of HBO max the Looney Tunes
swept Big Bang Theory The Sopranos Game
of Thrones and many other popular series
of the podium and is considered the most
watched series and the first week of HBO
max existence the new edition of the
series remains largely true to the
original but in one aspect it differs
from the original Elm of the FOB the
clumsy hunter and archenemy of Bugs
Bunny has probably got rid of his
shotgun the most famous trademark next
to his deerstalker cap has been removed
however he won't be able to go
completely without his guns because in
the series revival he will be allowed to
will his sickle and sky after all
another opponent of Bugs Bunny cowboy
juice Emily Sam is in a similar
situation he also has to get along
without his guns in the future and has
to be content with stabbing weapons so
the message of Warner Brothers and HBO
was clear the statement against gun
violence in the USA must be made
ironically this is not applied to
explosive weapons such as TNT or similar
because according to showrunner Peter
Brown yet they should not be dispensed
with violence yes but please not with
firearms Sam our strange approach after
all the French has lives from the comic
like overgrown scenes in which pianos
and anvils fall out characters or Bugs
Bunny once again escapes a completely
unrealistic trap set by hunter Elm of
the Fudd 80 episodes of 11 minutes each
are planned so far 30 of which are
already available on HBO max what do you
think about the new features on Looney
Tunes unconsidered action ISM or is the
film's do you even ride with its
position against violence with firearms
feel free to write in the comments
finally good news for fans of witcher
geralt after the resumption of shootings
was recently approved in great britain
under strict conditions the second
season of The Witcher is now also not
looking too bad as the fan site
retaining intelligence reports the
shooting of the second season is
scheduled to start again in the first
week of August 2020 and this is badly
needed after all the pandemic stopped
the production after only two weeks
according to retain Ian's intelligence a
little over four months of shooting are
still
necessary to get all the scenes shot so
it's not that unlikely that the final
shoot will be finished this year
provided that the strict regulations
don't interfere with the work too much
if everything goes well
even the plans start of the second
season in August 2021 is quite realistic
for the first season it took about seven
months for the complete post-production
including music editing and special
effects fans of The Witcher franchise
can therefore look forward to a
performance by Game of Thrones star
Christopher review as nevolin Gerald's
fellow witcher's lambert Cohen and his
mentor vism you will also be part of the
cast if you can't wait until the second
season you can also look forward to the
Witcher animated film nightmare of the
wolf the shooting of the Batman in Great
Britain will be continued in the near
future in the past few days a rumor has
been spreading about Batman number once
a bone and the future of the Batman for
one there is a persistent rumor that
Matt Reeves plans to make a trilogy out
of the news story about The Dark Knight
the confirmation or denial on behalf of
Warner or the director himself has
unfortunately not yet been made
additional rumors have been picked up by
the news portal comic book calm be more
precise Reeves is currently on the
lookout for a suitable actor for the
Joker according to some media reports
however he will not appear in the Batman
which is planned for 2021 but rather in
a potential second or third part the
basis for a later appearance of the
Joker is to be late in the upcoming
movie if these rumors come true Bruce
Wayne would have to deal with a large
number of villains so far officially
confirmed our Paul Dino as the Riddler
John Totoro as carmine Falcone and Colin
Farrell as the penguin even without the
Joker this is no easy task
especially since Batman will be in the
early stages of his superhero existence
in the upcoming movie how Robert
Pattinson was much reviled by fans will
perform in his role as Batman in the end
and what the Joker can actually be
expected to appear will become clear
with a release on 1st of October 2021
[Music]